who is cad bane how does his origin tied
to the original star wars trilogy and is
he really just a boba fett clone keep
watching for the untold truth of the
galaxy's most terrifying bounty hunter
today it's hard to imagine the era of
clone wars dominated star wars media
without thinking of cadbane arguably one
of the most famous characters created
for that original series initially
though cadbane wasn't supposed to be
part of the show at all in fact the
original landscape for the clone wars
had no room for third party players like
bounty hunters instead the focus of the
show's stories would exclusively remain
on republic and separatist forces as
production on the show progressed
however these plans changed bounty
hunters gradually began to be
incorporated into the show's story
though even by that point cab bane's
introduction was no sure thing on the
contrary his role in the clone wars was
to be filled by pre-existing characters
from star wars law such as dutch
[Music]
however once george lucas suggested
taking the character in a visual
approach more inspired by westerns a
more original idea emerged from the
ashes of these inaugural concepts came
carbane
the distinctive look of the aliens in
the star wars galaxy is one of the best
parts of this franchise honing down the
finer intricacies of the appearances of
these creatures is a difficult task
however and inspiration for an alien
design can strike from anywhere in the
case of cadbane the clone wars crew
found his look in the distant past
specifically his design came from a
piece of unused concept art for an alien
character in the original star wars
trilogy one with guns and holsters and a
gigantic rimmed hat the artist could
never have imagined it decades earlier
but this figure was exactly what the
clone wars team was looking for when it
came to cadbane clone wars producer dave
filoni has since explained that although
this may sound like an unlikely scenario
it's a common practice for star wars
media george lucas and other artists
would often come up with character names
or alien designs in the 1970s and
promptly abandon them only for them to
find the perfect home for them decades
down the road when you're a franchise
like star wars that spans for years and
years you never know when an idea might
get a second lease on life cad bane
engages in a lot of behavior that's
pretty harsh by the standards of
villains on animated kids tv shows in
his first appearance on the clone wars
he kills a galactic senator by shooting
them in the back while a subsequent
appearance depicts him torturing a jedi
for important information whenever bane
shows up he's bound to engage in
ruthless violence which is exactly why
this particular bounty hunter has
secured such a formidable reputation
among fans of the franchise however one
play spain couldn't cross the line was
smoking on one of the bonus features on
the box set for the fourth season of the
clone wars dave filoni comments that
bane's trademark toothpick was
originally supposed to be a cigarette
this would have aligned with the western
and noir inspirations for the character
as these two genres are known for
featuring characters who aren't afraid
to light one up every now and then the
difference was of course i've been
featured on an animated kids show rather
than say casablanca
is looking at you kid
so the cigarettes were ditched and bame
was forced to satisfy his penchant for
unruly behavior in other more vicious
ways
star wars the clone wars ground to a
halt in the spring of 2013 just a few
months after disney purchased lucasfilm
a sudden developments that left multiple
seasons worth of stories on the back
burner even after two bursts of clone
wars episodes were released across 2014
and 2020 much of the show's content
remained unreleased this is a fate that
befell a proposed storyline that would
have seen cad bane returning this time
as a mentor to a young boba fett though
bane was a central figure in these
episodes this arc was primarily a boba
fett origin story right down to him
getting his iconic mandalorian armor the
latter development was supposed to occur
during a shootout between bane and fett
which would have capped off the duo's
journey from student and master to
straight-up enemies made for the season
five development cycle of the clone wars
it's unknown why this storyline wasn't
finished and released for either of the
show's brief revivals however one reason
could be that the fed vs bane showdown
ended with bane's death it's possible
that the creative team behind the clone
wars opted to scrap this episode so that
bane could remain alive and well for
future appearances
it's hard not to see some similarities
between cadbane and boba fett and not
just because they're both bounty hunters
both are men of few words but aren't
afraid to show force when the moment's
call for it they also sport some of the
most distinctive outfits in the star
wars galaxy and are particularly well
known for their snazzy headgear however
the team behind the clone wars was
particularly conscious of bane coming
off as just a clone of a more popular
bounty hunter and did everything they
could to make him unique talking to
starwars.com directly after bane's first
appearance on the clone wars director
giancarlo volpe made sure to emphasize
that and like fett bane doesn't take
prisoners though a small distinction
this detail already suggests a world of
difference between the two bounty
hunters bane is supposed to be an even
darker version of fett and is an
important entity to have lingering
around as an adolescent fete navigates
the hate he has in his heart over the
death of his father notably bane's
ruthlessness and capacity for evil serve
to demonstrate what fett might become if
he doesn't change his ways quietly
introducing this thematic detail is one
of the many reasons that bane comes off
as more than just a boba fett
doppelganger
cadbane like so many other aspects of
the star wars mythos is heavily inspired
by classic cinema in particular
everything about the character's fashion
sense owes much to western protagonists
elsewhere one of the characters earliest
appearances introduces bane draped in
darkness and shards of light like a
character from a noir movie though
existing in a sci-fi world populated by
futuristic technology cad bane is very
much evocative of vintage pop culture so
it shouldn't come as much of a surprise
to hear that voice actor corey burton
looked to the pass for inspiration on
how to voice cadbane speaking to
starwars.com burton revealed that the
primary inspiration for the character's
vocals was the distinctive voice of
peter laurie specifically burton took
particular cues from laurie's more
subdued work on assorted luxe radio
theater programs the observant follows
in a few seconds unconsciousness
in two minutes or three minutes
death
however berta made sure to emphasize
that bane is not just a redux of lori's
voice he pointed out that both he and
the clone wars crew would use this
iconic classic movie actor as a starting
basis for the performance before taking
it in new directions
given how much talent from the clone
wars was ported over to star wars rebels
you'd assume that the former show's
recurring antagonist cadbane should have
been right in line for a guest
appearance the likelihood of that
happening seemed to increase once clone
wars fan favorite characters such as
ahsoka tano and captain rex made
appearances on the program and the
series even continued darth maul's
storyline from the clone wars if these
familiar faces could show up who's to
say cadbane couldn't unfortunately for
caribbean fans the bounty hunter was
missing from the entire run of rebels
even when other clone wars scoundrels
showed up bane was simply nowhere to be
found however eagle-eyed viewers may
have spotted the closest thing to a bane
cameo on the show in one particular
rebels episode in the form of bang
graffiti on a wall behind sabine though
just a background detail this easter egg
reminded viewers that bane is very much
alive and well in this era of star wars
even before disney bought lucasfilm star
wars tv shows were all about bringing in
familiar faces for surprise appearances
just look at how jabba the hurt factored
into the clone wars movie or the guest
appearance by greedo in a season 3
episode of the series this practice has
only become more pronounced in recent
years as luca's film attempts to
reinforce a sense of unified continuity
across all its various star wars
properties one example of this was cad
bane making a surprise appearance at the
2021 series star wars the bad batch
producer jennifer corbett explained to
skywalking through the netherlands that
having bane appear on the bad batch was
more than just providing a dose of fan
service to viewers the show had already
featured the leads facing off against
bounty hunter fenik shand and following
that formidable opponent the writers
wanted to introduce an even greater
threat for the protagonist to battle
this is where cadbane came into play as
corbett and the other bad batch
personnel felt he was one of the most
ruthless figures these characters could
go toe-to-toe with and if bringing back
this adversary reinforce a grander
fictional universe the bad batch
occupied well that was just gravy too
when cad bane reappears in the bad batch
making his first appearance in a
canonical star wars property in almost a
decade he looks a little different than
viewers might remember bane hasn't
undergone a radical transformation but
he's got a new ship and his clothes have
been tweaked a little too these weren't
incidental alterations though they were
intentional enhancements to the
character meant to take him into new
directions while also paying tribute to
unrealized storylines involving bane
from the clone wars director brad rau
explained to skywalking through
neverland for the design of cadbane we
were looking at some designs that never
got into production that were in
progress in clone wars it was a lot of
fun to sort of take them out of the
garage and tinker with it and push it
and rework it a little bit so that
campaign and his ride felt familiar and
yet a little bit more nuanced and more
detailed these differences also helped
to reinforce the passage of time between
bane's last appearance and the era of
star wars history in which the bad batch
occurs by taking this visual route the
show could tip its hat towards past star
wars television while also offering up
something new for a fan favorite
character
bringing cadbane back for the bad batch
didn't just offer an opportunity to make
fans of the bounty hunter as pleased as
punch it was also a chance to bring to
life certain story beats that the clone
wars never got to play out before its
cancellation of course given how much
time had passed between the first end of
the clone wars in 2013 and the 2021
debut of the bad batch it was clear that
the original concepts for bane's
storylines couldn't just be reused whole
cloth but they could be reinterpreted to
fit newly introduced characters in the
star wars mythos in an interview with
screen rant brad rau revealed that cad
bane's appearance and the bad batch was
steeped deeply in unused designs and
story lines from the clone wars the big
showdown between bane and new character
hunter was even based on the animation
and direction of the unused battle
between bane and boba fett from the
earlier series rao explained so it's
more of us as fans behind the scenes
wanting to pay homage to that when it
comes to this galaxy far far away no
idea is ever really gone
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more luba videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]